today marks
the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
we ask that you join us
in a gesture of solemn remembrance
as we take a moment of silence
to remember everyone affected by that
day's events
and reflect on our continued efforts
to never forget
beautiful ceremony here at the ballpark
as we remember
9 11.
20th anniversary of september 11.
miles michaelis is on the mound for st
louis tonight
we'll see if miles can get back to form
the way that he pitched a couple of
years ago here at busch stadium
and a fly ball into shallow right center
under it harrison boehner for the first
out
and the former cardinal hits it sharply
to goldie with time out number two
makes the play
six pitch inning for miles michaelis
luis castillo don't let that record fool
you this guy can be awfully tough and it
was a year ago the hyundai pitch arsenal
september 11th of 2020 he came in here
and he was awesome
fastball
truck slams into the wall loses the hat
but hangs out of the baseball
and it's low and outside ball four
gold schmidt's aboard with a one-hour
walk the 1-0 pitch chops up the middle
fielded by india right on top of second
steps on the bag throws to first in time
for the out 4-3 on the inning ending
double play and that closes out the
cardinals first third scoreless baseball
scoreless hitless
barnhart gets that one by
first reds base hit barnhart to second
base and that will bring jonathan india
to the play india golfs that one to
straight away center vader back on
the 20th home run of jonathan india's
rookie year
and the reds surge ahead two nothing
on his two out homer
shrock first pitch on a breaking ball
spanx that to center field castillanos
is grounded out
breaking ball destroyed oh castaianos
clubs into the bullpen more two out
thunder
another two run bomb
and a four nothing reds lead
that's a new career high 28 homers for
castillanos
and that is well hit
right center baiter is back and makes
the catch oh what a play bader in right
center
vader took extra bases away from joy
votto in right center paul deyoung will
take his first at bat of the night and
the reds leave it four nothing already
well hit
left center cardinals get on the board
and a long one off the battle pole to
yang
the cardinals shortstop now with 17.
and it's a 4-1 cincinnati lead
aldi young with his 17th home run of the
year and his third career home run off
luis castillo the cardinals trail by
three
the ball is jumping tonight
hit the other way and that's a base hit
for vader hustling out of the box and
thinking two on his way to second
sliding in
a home run and now a double
castillo's pitch tommy edmond singles
into right field an rbi hit
he drove that in between india and vato
into right field
and the cardinals are down by two
rbi number 48 for tommy edmond
and that one up the middle backhanded by
india fluid feed barrel bouncing throw
into oh my
oh a brilliant double play turned by the
reds
and all three men had a spectacular hand
in it the backhand the funnel
and the pick
assist cabrera the new pitcher in to be
interesting with cabrera i'm sure he's
amped up he's rested ready to roll we
know he's got a big arm here's the
bottle with a pop-up into left field
and the left fielder is there and he
makes the catch
one down
the fly ball goes to the left here to
pop a mile high
and
that's out number two
[Applause]
rounded to edmond charging on the play
off balance though had a long way to
come in as he is
in shallow right tyler o'neal 0 for two
o'neal swinging bunt hustling down the
line castillo's throw is not in time or
they call him out
and the cardinals obviously will take a
look at this as st louis does challenge
it's the second challenge
in this ball game we're gonna overturn
that call good challenge by st louis
a two-out hit and it extends the inning
to nolan aronado who flat out is due the
next to arnotto
pulled there down into the corner o'neal
was off of the pitch he's racing to
third he'll score easily
on his way to second now the third
misplayed out in left and he's safe
it's now a 4-3 game
gosh i love when that happens near the
offense he scored a ball down in the
corner great job by nolan right here he
stayed
with the change-up
battle battle battle two outs runner at
third
carlson a little flare out to shallow
center to play that wheel drop this game
is tied kevin on his way to second
[Music]
and a collision out in shallow center
and two reds are down it winds up being
a double and this game is tied up at 4-4
that's barrero there
the shortstop and naquin the
centerfielder coming in
round of applause as both players are at
least
somewhat up
he's going to come out of this game
great effort ball drops in and with that
we're tied up at 4-4 the
rbi double for dylan carlson to score
nolan aronado both runs have been scored
now with two outs
goldie walked in the first rounded into
a 4-6-3 double play in the third struck
out in the sixth
and that's a base hit into left center
goldie
extra bases
as well to second base
and the cardinals have the potential
go ahead running scoring position
at the end of the bat that'll roll fair
it's off the bag and advancing on the
play
it's goldschmidt to third well here's
arnado with the go ahead run at third
two outs
arenado hits it out to deep left how
about number 30. you bet
30 home runs
nolan oronato and what a time to do it
red birds on top
brewing
arnotto touches on plate congratulated
by paul goldsmith and the fans want a
curtain call from nolan oronato
giovanni gallegos fourth pitcher used by
st louis tonight
he goes five and five a 3.38 era an
opponent's average of 188 is six saves
he struck him out caught him looking for
the first doubt here in the ninth
there you go strikeout number two
ground ball this should do it mccoy
knows we're down four nothing they come
back and when it's 6-4 on this saturday
night
and it sets up the rubber game tomorrow
afternoon
you